hello i'm richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we dig into the
coverage and examine how news is
reported
given what is now unfolding in eastern
europe and the prospect of a wider
conflict between russia and the nato
alliance we are dispensing with our
usual format our starting point this
week is ukraine
with the last minute diplomacy failing
and the prospect of an invasion growing
from likely to inevitable news outlets
were relying on open source intelligence
evidence to show their audiences the
build-up of russian troops and armor on
the border with ukraine i know you've
been studying these satellite images
closely the troop movements the build-up
monday 5 p.m moscow time vladimir putin
assembles his security council at the
kremlin a made-for-tv meeting that if
nothing else produces some political
theater
[Music]
later that night in an hour-long speech
to the cameras putin denies that an
independent ukraine has a right to exist
roughly 48 hours later on wednesday
putin's ukrainian counterpart vladimir
zelensky
sends out a last-ditch message
[Music]
[Music]
it was too late the next day just before
5am local time putin announces what he
calls a special military operation to
protect russian-speaking ukrainians from
a potential genocide at the hands of
kiev in what has come to be a trademark
of war in the 21st century some of the
first images the world saw came from
somebody's phone
and as the scale of the invasion made
itself known it's tragic it's irrational
it's also evil many analysts on both
sides of the geopolitical divide had to
admit they got it wrong
a primary reason for that was the
incessant spin coming out of the kremlin
and the channels it controls was that
misinformation
or was it also an underestimation of
vladimir putin's willingness to go to
war
taking us through the russian side of
this global story now including cases of
misinformation coming out of moscow is
johanna huss well richard as we've
reported before this war is as much
about words as it is about weapons
for months as western media and
intelligence officers warned of an
imminent invasion russian news outlets
dismissed at times even parodied those
reports
unlike 2014 leading up to the annexation
of crimea when reporters on the russian
airwaves were beating the drums of war
we were seeing very little of that kind
of belligerent coverage
but that will change this past week
russian propaganda has kicked into gear
notably on state-owned
kremlin-controlled news channels tasked
with justifying the invasion
the push on russian tv is relentless or
echoing the kremlin's narrative on
alleged ukrainian aggression the need to
defend ukraine's russian-speaking
population from some kind
there are also videos reportedly
produced and staged by the kremlin of
supposed ukrainian attacks serving as a
pretext for war
misinformation beaming out of moscow is
not new russia has been honing these
kind of tactics for eight years ever
since its annexed crimea it is an
integral part of its hybrid war strategy
alexei novani russia's chilled
opposition figure and part-time
journalist has been tracking the
propaganda closely not by choice state
control tv is the only thing he is
allowed to watch now that he is behind
bars navalny's colleagues managed to put
out a series of tweets in his name in
which he said that the invasion of
ukraine and the media spectacle around
it are designed to distract russians
from the country's real issues a
faltering economy and a pattern of
extreme corruption at the kremlin
thanks joe
the conflict currently playing out in
ukraine involves former cold war
adversaries and competing versions of
history the russian president provided a
glimpse into his thinking last year when
the kremlin published an essay in
vladimir putin's name where he argued
that russians and ukrainians are of the
same slavic nation
he did it again this past week
questioning the very idea of ukrainian
statehood which does not go down well in
kiev washington or at nato's
headquarters in brussels but for putin
it's all part of a new historical
discourse one that emphasizes russia's
history as a great power and
mythologizes the country's past among
the victims of that historical rewrite
are russians themselves
the ones who have spent years
researching and remembering the victims
of political repression in what was the
soviet union
suddenly they found themselves on the
wrong side of the story and often on the
wrong side of the law the listening
posts tarik nafa now from moscow on the
battle over historical memory in russia
[Music]
december 28 2021
an abysmal year for free expression in
russia comes to a fitting conclusion
with the judge ordering the closure of
the country's oldest human rights
organization
[Music]
for more than 30 years memorial had
preserved records and artifacts from
joseph stalin's great purge when show
trials mass arrests and executions
touched every level of society
memorial's human rights center which has
also been shut down kept track of
political prisoners in russia today
assembling a vast online database of
repression in russia
what happened in court last year was
that the state exposed itself the
prosecutor spun the idea that memorial
does not paint the history of our
country in a positive light that it
demonizes the ussr as a terrorist state
when we started memorial the true scale
of the repression was absolutely hidden
memorial did a lot to open up the
archives
what is happening today is not just a
regression it is a crime against
citizens of russia because citizens have
the right to know their history
the main function of memorial was to
gather evidence of the national tragedy
our country experienced
my grandfather mark mikhailovich alberts
was shot on november the 1st 1937
more than 1 000 people like him were
shot the same day
they wanted to force him to admit that
he was a trotskyist
even though there wasn't a single shred
of evidence to support that
this was
memorial started functioning as a
political organization and that really
is a pity
i remember memorial when it was created
at the end of the 1980s as an
organization aiming to help the
relatives of people who were imprisoned
and to remember them
nowadays it has become an anti-russian
political organization
argument echoes that of the state which
has grown more defensive of russia's
historical legacy
when memorial first surfaced in the late
1980s things were different
citizens were seeking out the truth
about soviet state terror and relatively
little stood in their way
in 1990 members of memorial installed
this the solovetsky stone here in moscow
to honor victims of political repression
in soviet russia it was a period of
glasnost openness and transparency when
russians were learning about the
atrocities committed under joseph stalin
the decision to put it here in the
bianca square was significant we're
right across the road from what was the
kgb's headquarters now home to the fsb
the federal security services
but 30 years on some of those dark
chapters from russia's past are being
erased
history is being rewritten
when vladimir putin came to power
practically all the archives were closed
the people
was a short period available repression
but in reality
the whole governance system of the
soviet state was based on violence
there were a lot of chat that you know
stalin had nothing to do with that we
know now we have all these numbers this
is stalin irish of stalin that his uh
signature they were killed just because
you know there was the politics of
terror because
violence was the form of governors
that's it
for the current russian leadership the
kremlin history is a tool for
introducing certain myths into people's
minds
what we see today is the revenge of the
state security agencies which were in
retreat in the early 1990s
the state no longer wants to know the
truth about itself it builds its own
history and arranges it to fit its
ideological purposes
it's not that vladimir putin is denying
that political repression took place in
2017 he unveiled this the ward of grief
russia's first official monument to
those killed by stalin
putin said this terrifying past cannot
be deleted from national memory but
little by little the russian state has
reclaimed sole custody of russia's
memory the focus is not on the crimes of
the past but on the triumphs
particularly the victory over the nazis
in world war ii which has become a
central pillar in a story that's all
about russian greatness
a campaign to sanctify russia's war
heroes is playing out in popular culture
and in public space
the government has championed patriotic
films that lionize the military and
affirm its use of force
[Music]
[Music]
many of these state-funded blockbusters
center on stalin's leadership in what is
known in russia as the great patriotic
warning
moscow is filled with tributes to
historical figures patriots who ensured
the survival of the state
it's where you can find pop-up
propaganda showcasing russia's military
arsenal
some of these murals are sponsored by
historical associations run by senior
officials close to the president
including this one opposite the kremlin
it was commissioned by the russian
military historical society where
mikhail mikhov is scientific director
the victory of the soviet army in the
second world war has a crucial role in
how russians self-identify we have to
hold on to some constants such as our
victories during the patriotic war of
1812 the first world war or the great
patriotic war
these allow us to feel self-sufficient
in this world we can say to other
nations we gave you freedom
we live in a world that was created by
the soviet union in 1945
missing from that narrative are
inconvenient periods of history like
august 1939 when joseph stalin and adolf
hitler agreed to a non-aggression pact
arguably paving the way for a world war
that started one week later
over time stalin's legacy once so
discredited has been rehabilitated in
2019 a survey by the lavada center found
70 percent of russians thought he had
played a positive role in russian
history
people are constantly told that without
stalin the russians would not have won
the war
stalin
putin has nothing else to offer russian
citizens
he cannot offer them wealth and
prosperity and that is why he is only
offering the myths of some great periods
in history
having shaped a grand historical
narrative about russia's place in the
world vladimir putin now wants to
protect it
a new national security strategy signed
by putin in 2021 says traditional
russian values and historical memory are
under attack and must be defended
before russia invaded ukraine this week
putin once more revealed his obsession
with writing past wrongs by questioning
ukraine's historical right to exist
i would never have believed it 30 years
ago if someone would have told me all
this would begin to repeat itself we
have not learned any worthy lessons from
history
any state any community of people often
live with myths about the past but all
myth-making begins with a set of values
what is valuable for the group of people
now leading russia
to remain in power forever to consume to
occupy
we can see that now with the revenge's
speech on ukraine and to convince
everyone that the state is an absolutely
sacred object
which cannot be encroached on in any way
[Music]
one political leader who may be grateful
that the eyes of the news world are now
trained on ukraine and not on his
country would be india's narendra modi
with elections either underway or
looming in some key states modi's
bhartiya janata party the bjp
keeps playing its hindu nationalist
anti-muslim card the vast majority of
indian news outlets are not just okay
with that approach they adopt it
themselves sometimes out of fear of the
authorities should they criticize modi
or because conflict sells and attracts
viewers in one of the world's most
competitive news markets
india likes to brand itself as the
world's biggest democracy is that really
the case true democracies have
independent media outlets that hold
governments to account that is not the
case in narendra modi's india
politics do not get much uglier than
what india has to offer in 2022
this post with its stereotyping and dog
whistling showing the hanging of indian
muslims promising terrorists will see no
mercy is not the work of a radical
fringe
it comes from an official account of the
bjp the country's ruling party and was
posted by its communications team in
gujarat a state that will hold an
election later this year
gujarat was once home to prime minister
narendra modi it is where he shaped his
politics made his name
stereotyping a community through its
clothing and then showing
members of that community hanging from a
news is not something that would be
acceptable in any democracy in the world
and it shouldn't be it has become
acceptable in this country and it
requires a lot of work from activists to
be able to take such material off social
media gujarat is mr modi's home state
and for the twitter handle of the ruling
party for the instagram handle of the
ruling party to post an image of muslim
men
hanging by the news i mean the message
could not be clearer i checked the
reactions you know on my social media
and even people who are usually fen
sitters quote unquote apolitical even
they were completely gobsmacked by this
their reactions were okay this is our
ruling party what is happening how is
this normal how is this completely
acceptable in this day and age but of
course we have we can't look at this
cartoon in isolation
not with what's been coming out of uttar
pradesh
up is india's most populous state more
than 200 million people live there it is
in the middle of its own state election
one that is seen as a bellwether for
national elections that are two years
away
narendra modi's man in up is chief
minister yogi
when this interviewer asked him about
another politician a prominent muslim
adityanat used a term to describe
muslims a slur related to the islamic
practice of circumcision one that does
not quite translate into english but was
extraordinarily offensive
the interviewer just carried off
the word kathmullah refers to somebody
who's fanatical and obstinate and
because it contains the word mullah it
refers specifically to muslims
it is not surprising that this man used
the term he's used much worse it is not
surprising either that the television
host who asked him the question which
got this response didn't react more
strongly than she should have far too
many news outlets seem to have decided
that it is the opposition that has to be
grilled not the ruling party
you see it every night on primetime news
the the topics the hashtags the
headlines all the combativeness is
directed at the opposition
so tv news continues to thrive on
confrontation in india
it's just that it's no longer speaking
true to power instead it is speaking on
behalf of power
and providing power with a platform even
when that's against the rules
this interview modi did with ani a
national news agency should not have
been aired since it took place within 48
hours of the polls opening in uttar
pradesh that is a black and white breach
of india's electoral laws
modi did it anyway and the electoral
commission has yet to be heard from
at one point in fact the prime minister
is not even looking uh at the interview
directly he just turns around and looks
at the camera
so there's not even like a farce of this
being some sort of dialogue between two
people which just tells you
what this interview supposedly was all
about that interviews then circulated
and carried by pretty much every
publication in the country narendra modi
in the last
seven over seven years that he's been
prime minister he has not addressed a
single press conference
he has
never given journalists the chance to
ask him
questions
off the cuff
the only media appearances that he makes
are well scripted television interviews
the questions are always softball
and we haven't really seen an interview
yet where
anyone has ever grilled the prime
minister or asked proven questions of
him
it's not for a lack of journalists or
news outlets india's media ecosystem is
the world's largest almost
424-hour television news channels tens
of thousands of newspapers and websites
since 2014 when narendra modi was first
elected prime minister the vast majority
of those channels have become pro bjp
modi's brand of nationalism is built on
conflict pitting the hindu majority
against muslims with some anti-christian
content thrown in you don't believe
peddling conflict also happens to be a
winning formula in the 24-hour news game
it's bad for populations but good for
ratings
stray from the consensus as rana ayub
has done through her reporting and you
risk facing vilification even death
threats from online activists or legal
investigations and court cases brought
by the authorities we contacted multiple
bjp spokespeople with questions about
this story we got nothing back they
don't feel it necessary to respond
because they have their own ecosystem
they have their own set of news anchors
who have kind of already built this
image of western media as propagandist
this narrative that whether it's the
washington post or al jazeera or new
york times they're all here to spread a
propaganda against narendra modi every
time a critical question is asked the
new york times has done it again the
american newspaper's latest article on
the pulvama terror attack is an example
of how western media misleads readers
because
the government has been able to
successfully
enter
average indian middle class drawing
rooms via news channels or just simply
frankly whatsapp forwards
there is almost this sense of
insurmountable
impunity with which the government acts
to the point that no amount of criticism
will get to them that we don't need
the independent media or we don't need
the foreign media to listen to us or
platform us
foreign
india's media ecosystem has been known
to feed on itself as it did in gujarat
after twitter took down that tweet for
violating its rules the bjp said it did
not intend to target muslims that
newspapers and tv channels show images
of criminals and that the caricature was
based on them
that is how what goes around in the
indian news media the hate comes around
and it does so at the expense of other
stories of fundamental importance that
go on or under reported stories such as
how are hundreds of millions of indians
going to feed themselves today
60
of india's population is dependent on
free grain 800 million individuals the
primary narrative in india is not about
poverty there are no debates on the
economy what we hear every night is
islamophobia are they not forcing their
views on their children how can we
persecute muslims today and on what
subject whom they cannot marry where
they cannot stay what they cannot wear
and the responsibility of this falls on
the free and independent media of this
country they have chosen to do what they
do
every night
where they echo
what the government says every night and
it is because of them in large measure
that the present and the future look
quite new
[Applause]
and finally back to the ukraine story
one of the russian news channels that
carried vladimir putin's speech this
past monday was rt
its editor-in-chief margarita simonian
has been busy overseeing the channel's
coverage bouncing from talk show to talk
show often showing up on other
state-owned news channels like rocia1
where she has a frequent presence on
anchorman vladimir siloviov's program
they've attracted big audiences and at
least a few viewers in brussels at the
european union who disapprove of their
kind of journalism simonian and soloviov
have both been hit with sanctions by the
eu which calls them propagandists we're
leaving you now with a few excerpts of
the kind of news coverage brussels is
talking about and we'll see you next
time here at the listening post
space
[Music]
[Music]
foreign